哎，
就你们这情况，
以后负担可太重了，
这孩子天宫开局，
生下来就背负着七八个人的养老问题，
我36岁，
我老公34岁，
感情都还挺好的，
公婆也还好，
之前30岁做过试管，
三处两仪，
失败了，
没有胚胎了，
我有风湿性关节炎，
以前工作有时候经常会腿疼，
现在我试管完之后找了一份工作，
我自己比较喜欢，
工资大概是5000多，
有五险一金，
我老公8000多，
做那个建筑测量方面的装修行业，
但是这个行业现在走下坡路，
存款大概有80个W，
两边父母都是农村的，
存款大概就是10多个W，
我就是现在这个年龄也不好找工作了，
我老公国企的这一行再走下坡路嘛，
很多人都在待业，
我要宝宝怕以后没有精神寄托，
老了也怕太孤独了，
我这边怕去做试管对自己身体有伤害嘛，
怕到时候全程两空，
工作也不好找。
你俩之所以要做试管，
是谁的原因啊？
主要是我的原因吧，
首先我是做了宫腹腔镜，
已经做过手术，
做过手术之后没有怀上，
一年后就去做了试管。
你们两口子生育的意愿主要是来自于谁呀？
谁更想生孩子？
我老公主要看我的意见，
我妈妈催我很厉害，
他说如果我再不做试管就惩罚自己，
他给我发了一篇这样的文章，
你本人很渴望做妈妈，
很喜欢小孩子的人吗？
你要。
真实的面对自己，
诚实的面对自己，
不是非要不可吧，
如果是我一定想要，
我也应该也不会来问你了，
但是我应该也不是不想要，
你还想要吧？
现在比较纠结风湿性关节炎的那个问题，
这孩子会对你的身体造成很大的损伤呢，
我风湿性关节炎是比较轻微的，
突然变天或者突然走很多路的话，
我这腿就经翅会疼，
因为现在这份工作的原因就很少疼了，
那你现在这份工作，
如果你要怀孕生孩子，
这份工作就保不住是吗？
对，
是的，
公司特别忙，
那你老公的工作收入到手多少钱？
8000左右吧，
你的公公婆婆也是农村的吗？
是的，
你的爸爸妈妈也是农村的吗？
他们都没有养老保险，
都没有退休金，
然后你是独生子女，
你的老公是独生子女吗？
他们两个都是独生子女，
妈耶，
就你们这情况，
以后负担可太重了，
如果你没有收入，
光靠你老公那8000块钱，
加里四个老人，
加上你，
加上小孩儿，
他一个人养六个人，
而且我老公现在这一行也不好了，
再做两个月他可能待业，
也不知道下一份会有没有工作，
一人在国土，
但是这一行现在很不好，
这孩子天崩开局，
生下来就背负着七八个人的养老问题，
你有房子有车吗？
有车，
房子是19年买的，
大概80万左右，
现在已经贬值了，
在三四线城市，
我现在是在我们这边。
在省会城市上班，
你老公呢？
他是建筑装修行业嘛，
他一个工地完了之后交要换地方，
不稳定，
所以没有和他在一起，
那将来生了孩子了之后，
也是跟老公是异地的状态吗？
是的，
因为你的情况跟别人不一样，
别人可能想怀想生的话，
人家成本代价没有那么大，
但你要想怀想生的话，
只有20万存款，
你要做试管，
这10万块钱可未必够用啊。
对，
是的，
上次单纯两仪就用了十几万。
对，
你的情况跟别人不一样，
试管又花去十几万，
你手上总共就20万存款，
你老公一个月就8000块钱工资，
那以后你不挣钱了，
两边老人都没有养老保险，
都没有退休金，
谁家老人上趟医院不得两三万打底，
生点大病不得三五万打底，
这日子真的我替你着急，
我知道了第二个问题就是怎么面对我妈妈说我这试管就成个你，
很多老人呢，
是张着嘴提要求，
但他不给钱，
你知道吗？
凡是那种说不给钱，
张着嘴提要求的老人的话，
在我看来都是无德，
我就这么自私，
说话就这么难听，
我心里就是这么想的，
不给钱张着嘴提要求的老人都是无德的，
但是说说使万就给我5万，
但是给我好像解决不了我什么问题，
那我该怎么面对他呢？
就答应啊，
说没问题，
妈，
你放心吧，
我都在调理身体了，
嘴上一套心里后，
医生跟我说了要在观察观察，
现在还不适合做下一次，
又说没。
分工最好是把钱拿过来，
说我要去做，
这招有点太坏了，
仅限于像龙飞这样的坏人可以用，
像你们道德感太高了，
未必能用好的，
我知道了，
拜拜啊。
刚刚有个朋友说多少钱才够，
他情况跟咱们不太一样，
他的情况是她想要生这个孩子的话，
她工作就得丢，
这是其一，
其二是她之前已经做过三错两仪了，
都失败了，
其三是她老公这个工作也不稳定，
也在走下坡路，
而她老公一个月就挣8000块钱，
关键是四个老人都没有退休金，
四个老人都是农村的，
没有养老保险，
没有医疗保险，
她如果想要生孩子的话，
她还得做使万，
未必说一次能成功，
还得砸进去十几万，
所以她情况跟大家不太一样，
所以这种情况的话，
我觉得自然能怀上，
咱就自然就生，
别着急去做试管了，
全是花钱的地方，
现在谁家老人稍微摔一下啦，
磕一下啦，
碰一下了，
去趟医院不得一两万打底交押金啊，
可以去看看中什么什么一把身体调理的棒棒的，
心情也好啊，
记得点赞关注哦。